there's tons of black men crowding jails
for an eighth of weed while white men
have weed parties and it's cool and
that's their thing but like black men
are automatically arrested for it do you
have any statistical data to prove that
black men with nothing more than an e of
weed go to prison I couldn't give you
the exact statistics but there's several
accounts of it and it's not unknown it's
pretty much common sense that blacks are
way easily more arrested than white men
do you agree with what was just stated
there as a blackmail no you didn't even
have to think about it what part do you
disagree the statistics about black
crime and Rel brutality overly affecting
black males I mean we have to look at
crime statistics so yes black males are
overrepresented in prisons but black
males also over represented in crime
statistics people can make the argument
that it's oh it's because of white
oppression I don't necessarily think
it's because of white oppression I think
it has a lot to do with the welfare
state I think it has a lot to do with
Democratic policies and liberal policies
pushing agendas upon black people
instead of giving them agency and
allowing them make their own decisions